ich bin so witzig ein dislike
[Musik]
unter der dunklen trial da versteht man
in der psychologie nazismus psychopathie
und materialismus drei sozial schädliche
eigenschaften die nicht selten zusammen
auftreten während die dunkle triade vor
allem bei menschen in machtpositionen
besonders ausgeprägt sein sollen dem
psychologen davon aus dass diese drei
dunklen charaktereigenschaften in jedem
fall geständig
fragt sich nur nicht heute beginnen wir
mit teil 1 dieser dreiteiligen serie und
zwar mit rassismus ob donald trump oder
kylie jenner narzisstische also
selbstverliebte menschen springen uns
tagtäglich aus dem fernsehen oder dem
handy entgegen
und dass jemand der gerne vor der kamera
steht muss auch ich von einem
überdurchschnittlich ausgeprägten
nazismus ausgehen heißt es muss
eigentlich genau bei nazismus
unterscheidet man zwischen normalem
nicht pathologisch nazismus als
charaktereigenschaft und einer
narzisstischen persönlichkeitsstörung
die ganz offiziell im diagnostik
entwickeln annual of mental disorders
aufgeführt ist zeichen dass du an einer
narzisstischen persönlichkeitsstörung
leidest du wirkst auf deine mitmenschen
arrogant überheblich und angeberisch
naja aber schließlich bist du auch
anderen menschen überlegen davon bis zu
überzeugt du fühlst dich enteilt wie man
im englischen sagen würde das heißt du
wirst wütend oder ungeduldig wenn man
sich nicht als den besonders besonderen
menschen behandelt der du bist du
übertreibst bei deinen leistungen und
talenten und besteht darauf und allem
das beste zu haben die besten noten das
beste auto die beste frau gleichzeitig
tust du dir wirklich schwer mit kritik
insgeheim belasten dich deine
unsicherheits charme und verlässlichkeit
auf kritik reagiert du deswegen oft mit
hut oder verachtung und nike seine
kritiker schlecht zu machen um deine
überlegenheit nicht zu gefährden
trotz sozialer und verträglichkeit
strahlen menschen mit ausgeprägter
dunkle triade nicht selten eine gewisse
anziehungskraft aus es ist zum beispiel
nachgewiesen dass narzissten oft einen
besseren ersten eindruck hinterlassen
wenn sie sich neun menschen vorstellen
durch attraktivere körpersprache mimik
und nicht selten bessere kleidung hey
ich würde mich selbst so klasse dass du
es auch glaubst außerdem fanden
wissenschaftler heraus dass rassisten im
schnitt mehr verdienen auch wenn es bloß
nicht in verbindung mit
führungspositionen steht da spielen
psychopathin machiavellis muss eine
größere rolle
die ausgeprägt ist eure dunkle triade
das könnt ihr rausfinden mit einem
kleinen quiz dass die iwc in
zusammenarbeit mit wissenschaftlern
erstellt hat werde ich oft unten dass es
in übrigens meine ergebnisse sowie
zuteil als jeweils ein video zu
psychopathie und materialismus folgen
dann die nächste mal in den kommentare
welche der dunklen trainer bei euch am
meisten ausgeprägt ist und abonniert
mich bitter denn wir gesehen hat bin ich
natürlich bereit und ich brauche eure
anerkennung